>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOLLOWING THE RELEASE
OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE MEMO ON FRIDAY, DONALD
TRUMP, JR. SAID IT WAS A PIECE
OF SWEET REVENGE FOR HIS FAMILY
IN PROOF THAT THE ENTIRE RUSSIAN
DONALD TRUMP, JR. JOINS US
TONIGHT.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THE
MEMO?
SCARED ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON.
YOU DON'T THINK OF THIS
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES.
HAPPENING IN A COUNTRY WHERE WE
HAVE A FOUNDATION OF LAWS AND
PRINCIPLES GROUNDED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS A CLEAR VIOLATION OF
SURVEILLANCE OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS, IN THIS CASE THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, BASED ON SHADY
INFORMATION PAID FOR BY THE
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE IN
THAT PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
THIS IS CRAZY STUFF.
WRITTEN TO ALLOW.
IT IS ALLOWED UNDER THE LAW AND
THAT LAW WAS REAUTHORIZED BY THE
REPUBLICAN CONTROLLED CONGRESS
WITH LITTLE DEBATE.
WHY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THEY WANT TO RE-VISIT
THAT.
AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN TO SEE
THIS STUFF GOING ON, TO TRY TO
SUBVERT DEMOCRACY THIS WAY BASED
ON THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE SO BIAS
ON THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE SO BIA
BIASSED, THAT'S SCARY.
IT'S ONE THING IF YOU ARE DOING
HAVE HERE.
>> Tucker: ALL OF THE THINGS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT WERE ALLEGEDLY
COMMITTEED BY EMPLOYEES OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH WHICH IS NOW
THE TRUMP EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
HOW DO YOU FIX THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK WE HAVE TO OPEN
EVERYTHING UP.
LISTEN TO THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO.
DOING THIS.
WE HAVE BEEN IN A ONE SIDED
BATTLE.
REPUBLICANS CAN HAVE THEIR
TALKING POINTS AND THERE IS BIAS
THERE AS WELL.
WHEN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
WILLING TO GO TO BATTLE FOR
ANYTHING THE OTHER SIDE SAYS AND
SAY, THAT IS THE GOSPEL.
THAT'S WHERE IT GETS SCARY.
TRANSCRIPTS AND EVERYTHING THAT
WENT INTO THIS.
I THINK ONCE ALL OF THAT COMES
OUT, NOT JUST THE REBUTTAL THEY
HAD WEEKS TO SAY, THIS IS HOW WE
WILL COUNTER IT, BUT LET'S SEE
THE COURT TRANSCRIPTS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THAT JUDGE
SAW WHEN THEY RE-AUTHORIZED IT.
IT WAS BASED ON CARTER PAGE AND
RE-AUTHORIZED AFTER HE WAS NOT
EVEN A PART OF THE CAMPAIGN
ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: THE REBUTTAL SCHIFF
THAT WILL GO TO THE PRESIDENT.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL ALL GET TO SEE
IT SOON.
THEY DIDN'T APPLAUD THE
DECLASSIFICATION OF THE NUNES
MEMO?
WAS IT STRIKEING TO SEE
REPORTERS ARGUE FOR MORE
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY
INVESTIGATE PEOPLE!
WE WILL BE GIVING UP TRADE
TALKING POINTS TO PREVENT IT
FROM COMING OUT.
THE MEDIA WAS WILLING TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE KNEW THE SKY WAS
>> Tucker: NONE OF THE PEOPLE
HAD SEEN THE MEMO?
>> WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY KNEW OR
WHAT THEY HAD SEEN?
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IN THEY
DID KNOW.
>> Tucker: YOUR TAKE ON CARTER
PAGE AT THE CENTER OF THAT MEMO
WHICH DESCRIBED HOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPIED ON HIM?
>> I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS A LOW LEVEL PERSON WHO
WORKED ON THE CAMPAIGN.
THERE WAS AN EMAIL THAT THIS
ONE FAMILY MEMBER SAID WHO IS
THE HECK IS THAT INDIVIDUAL?
TO DID THAT TO ATTACK THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT AFTER THAT
PERSON IS NO LONGER PART OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE A PART OF
SOMEBODY.
THE REALITY IS HE WAS NOT A REAL
PLAYER IN THE CAMPAIGN.
TO UTILIZE THAT PERSON.
MAKES HIM A GREAT PATSY FOR
THAT.
THE REALITY OF THE SITUATION
ANSWER WE HAD AN INVESTIGATION
GOING ON FOR OVER 2 YEARS WHERE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO ALL OF THE
SHADE, ALL OF THE STUFF GOING ON
HAPPENED.
ON A CAMPAIGN.
UTILIZE THAT TO GET ALL OF THESE
FISA WARRANTS TO SPY ON SOMEBODY
WHO BECOMES THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I MEAN, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
DID IS REEK OF A BANANA